feeling enlightened just as well looks
like you've picked up some attention
prepare for your my name is David
Tennant I'm an actor
I've never done a video game before I
suppose I mean I usually do more
traditional forms of acting work on you
know TV into the old film and stage play
I suppose so this is a first for me
welcome to the global competition
welcome to connect Sports rivals I'm
sort of the voice of God I suppose I'm
the voice that comes on and tells you
how it all works your own one of a kind
face
unless you've got a twin or an evil
clone I think it's it's clearly
brilliantly that this technology can
replicate you what we know right now is
that you're ready for action I don't
know that I'm the person to come to for
sporting tips my greatest sporting
achievement personally it was probably
an egg and spoon race that I a stat some
point in my childhood you gained some
fans by competing and more cooling off
chromed pleaser I remember it's only
home computer games really from from
their birth i'm you know i remember
playing pong that's what was cold wasn't
it with the two paddles I never claimed
that and it felt like it felt like the
world had opened up in a way that none
of us had ever dreamed would be possible
the last game I played with any kind of
tenacity was Arkham Asylum but even
that's getting a few years old now but I
keep an eye and I my son's a very keen
gamer so I I have a vague connection
through him and I sort of know a bit of
what's going on
we don't just create legends we create
worlds this is the island your proving
ground where you'll lock horns with
rivals and Thunder through events to be
reborn as a sporting title I did a rock
climbing look good I quite like the
slightly unsportsmanlike element where
you can grab a rival through Chuck from
off the side of the cliff I'd go with
that good
when you said rare I didn't realize you
meant rheya
I meant I thought you meant rheya only
on Xbox one